[Music]
i mean the pattern that we've mentioned
and we've been discussing now the
pattern of uk investment for instance if
i think of nigeria and parts of africa i
think maintains that colonial pattern
because it's very focused on minerals
for some of the reasons that have been
mentioned here it's easier um your
profit margins are larger so it makes
more sense to do that and then the
narratives we're hearing also about the
sort of post-brexit um engagement is you
know we have a special relationship you
know we have something in place already
um let's continue to work with that so
if we're thinking of it in that way i
think yes we can make that argument if
we think of the impact also that so i
like this point about you know making
yourself attractive making yourself
ready but the reason why countries are
not attractive and ready are linked also
to that colonial experience they didn't
just appear not ready or you know not
suitable a lot of that is linked to that
why is south africa ready why is south
africa very attractive because of its
apartheid history because it's a
situation where you have been able to
exploit the majority for a minority and
put in place the kind of infrastructure
that is today very attractive you know
so we have to deal with a lot of those
realities you know why why can't you
look the way you have to look there are
reasons to it those countries are not
here even when you think of the conflict
and many of the syrians conflict is
linked also to its colonial history that
is partly why it cannot present itself
you know you know in some regards it is
and nowadays it's trying to clean up the
conversations with the kimberley um
initiative and all of that but a lot of
those problems are very much linked to
that colonial experience now if we come
i mean there's been a lot of reference
to what is going on with china as well
and one can and there are debates around
the extent to which there is a path
dependency so here we have a somewhat a
semi-periphery context
and we have to complicate that global
north global south
narrative because we have china um on
the stage now and sometimes we are
seeing a relationship that mirrors that
conversation about the you know the west
the global north however you want to
term it and economies at the moment um
so we you know i think there's much to
be said around that it is true you do
see
investments that come in the extent to
which you're thinking about technology
transfer has been criticized that you
don't you're not seeing that exchange
the sort of the importation of capital
the importation of labor um you know so
that there's very little technology
retained in that context however the
flip side i think of this debate and
this argument stefan has also referenced
the ethiopia uh situation i've also
worked on ethiopia looking at chinese
investment in um in the leather industry
and you know my own research findings
were that you did see
certain degrees of technology transfer
you did see you know certain
improvements knowledge transfer that
meant um uh you know you you had better
access to the inputs you needed or
required there was an expansion in
production expansion in exports as well
so all of those things that you want to
see and for ethiopia that investment is
very important because of the savings
gap ethiopia doesn't have the sort of
mineral resources that other economies
have but what you did see also in that
situation was a neglect of domestic
producers right so all of this
improvement was being dominated by these
foreign investors and you have a very
vibrant leather industry um in ethiopia
but the domestic producers were not
benefiting from that and there was a
neglect even of that um a local market
where they were now importing chinese
footwear for instance instead of
utilizing this newly produced
this expansion
in production of leather goods so it is
a complex picture another final point on
on the different what i see as a
difference with china is the investment
and infrastructure and i would argue
that
for all the challenges and problems and
it's true what stefan has said about the
the costing around the kenyan uh rail
this has been very topical you know i'm
nigerian and i grew up you know in in in
that context and it is only now i'm
seeing trains that are moving you know i
have siblings who get on the train and
go from one city to another this sounds
i mean to me i look at it and i cannot
believe that is my country and there are
a lot of and don't get me wrong there
are a lot of challenges with how a lot
of those contracts have been negotiated
the elites that are benefiting from that
arrangement but there are trains that
are working and moving and people can
live in another city and go and work in
another city you know if you know if
anyone has been in lagos traffic you
will appreciate uh you know the benefit
of this sort of infrastructure
investment the investments in energy
hydroelectric dams and this move by
china is challenging
europeans and
americans in how they think about
investment in africa infrastructure used
to be a sort of no no who's going to do
that cost too much you can't afford it
but the narrative on that has changed
thank you um
can i disagree about something please
that would be just think i mean i'm
sorry if it's but
i'll give you lots of time to you but
so i just want on quickly on three
things there one from things that you
said
and the first one is the disagreement is
on you know of course colonialism and
his we cannot ever look at the present
without recognizing history but i just
want to emphasize
how the heterogeneity of experience
again is it how certain countries can do
it so there is no predestination we
should just be very careful with it
vince mentioned already botswana
botswana is an interesting case in that
sense it can actually overcome look it
is structures of economies and can worry
about it but it is definitely a much
better functioning society that you will
be happily maybe disagree with there on
it but but they say compared to nigeria
and i think i'm close to home for you
is there is there issues as well so
there is something there about
can you learn to begin to overcome this
and i think that's what what we see more
and more in african countries is that
some countries are consciously trying to
overcome some of these structures
because there's nothing against across
the world not in national resource
investments in itself australia has lots
of natural resource investments in
itself in fact in africa of course it's
not britain that's the biggest
investment it's actually canada is uh is
the biggest one
that i uh that do this and so we have
economies that can do it so indonesia
was a country with lots of natural
resources but then it consciously made
itself attractive for these other things
and so that's the bigger problem there
actually another thing on the technology
transfer and it's really interesting
that you say because you know i've
worked a lot in ethiopia as well is that
one of the things is often also with
domestic industries is that they
actually struggle with scale
and it's actually often managerial
capabilities not that they can be a good
manager or not but just how do you
organize at scale for international
markets and this is actually one of the
biggest benefits from from fdi so the
technology is often managerial
and don't get me wrong it's not because
then africans can't be good managers but
it's actually it's a complicated thing
to actually start running a very large
large scale and it's not the technology
transfer of the machine or whatever and
then the final thing on the
infrastructure i'm very tempted to say
let's hope the trains keep on running
because we've had these phases with
infrastructure investments that is the
in time as well but that's maybe where i
would support you and that's actually
where it's a really interesting time
in the us they now really have woken up
that actually we need to make an offer
no the best thing for africa now is that
everywhere wakes up we also need to make
these offers a benign scramble exactly
and it's just great for once people want
to try to do things so i i just wanted
to say a bit more about our favorite
subject which is chinese investment in
africa and just to draw on some of the
conclusions of the work i think there's
there are big things happening but
they're very different things that first
of all there are they what you might
call the risk investors the equity
investors real business people and
the certainly the african capitals i've
been to are absolutely buzzing with
chinese businessmen
and they are hustling you know and you
don't get british businessmen hustling
in africa they're giving up
and americans and most europeans they're
no longer there you know particularly
small medium-sized companies they don't
go anywhere near africa very few of them
but so the chinese have moved in
actually has the the indians also
there's lots of indian investment now
and these these are the risk takers um
and some of them are terrible awful
you know and
then they're doing what you could
describe you know some of them they're
they're they're only roll their
wholesaling imports of local
shoes and ruining local industries but
some of them are serious investors who
are putting up factories and doing
useful things and being very productive
and unlike western companies tend to
have a very long time time frame
uh you know the huawei's of the future
you know i think in 20 30 years ahead so
it's a very mixed story but you've got
to distinguish
them the real business people
from the banks you know the the the the
the big chinese banks
are lending vast amounts of money in
africa for these big infrastructure
projects like the kenya railway the
ethiopia railway and they're under a
program which is actually promoted by
the chinese government you know it's a
president g's uh signature policy the
bri
and you know they they are doing it
again because the western world is
largely evacuated
africa in in terms of infrastructure
investment it's very difficult to get
apart from the world bank
one to other institution it's very
difficult to get
western institutions to invest in
physical infrastructure
and it's partly you know squeamishness
you know not wanting to get involved
but but it is also we've you know people
have walked away and the chinese are
some extent filling the gap
and some of those projects are
good as far as one can judge some of
them are very uh tacky um
and
they've adopted the practice of western
creditors
of ensuring that they have proper
collateral but and
and that can be
uh very threatening you know as you say
the the kenya the the kenya government
seeded as collateral for their railway
uh the port of mombasa and taking dues
from the post of mombasa this is not the
first example of of that kind of
calamity no that kind of thing happened
but they you know
it goes back to the answer at the
beginning supposing that those people
were turned down and we said well they
were just not going to accept this kind
of conditionality the the alternative of
course is that nothing happens um and
there's a really difficult choice here
you know do you want
bad investments half bad investments or
no investment and that's often that's
often the choice
is that how you see the choice i i mean
wait this is bringing us to
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas